what's going on guys this is rob and um
it is like
3 45 in the morning and i've been
working on some videos for the last i
don't know about um
about four hours or so and um you know
i'm getting them all prepared and what
we're going to do this week is initially
i wanted to get stuff done on monday but
there's just not enough time so
throughout all this week we're going to
be uploading videos we're going to be
bringing videos out a couple of videos a
day hopefully
and we can get through all these times
so that when next monday comes around we
can start civil war issue number five
i'm sorry to kind of keep pushing that
back you know um i don't like having to
do that
but with this we can be in the fourth of
july with it being as chaotic it was you
know and of course hanging out with my
dad
while he was in town i wanted to make
sure that you know i brought you guys
the content that you wanted to see
but i wanted to make sure that the
important things that were going on here
in
town that i was actually engaging in
those of course when my dad comes to
town it's important that i have time to
hang out with him and so
you know um it's really going to be kind
of cool like today i'm going to be
seeing him hanging out with him before
he goes home but
nonetheless you know i think that you
guys are going to enjoy the content that
we have coming up this week i think you
guys are going to like
what's going on this week we're going to
be getting into discussions about miss
marvel we're going to be talking about
heroes for hire
we're going to be talking about some
pretty cool groups and we're really
going to kind of be talking about these
in a way where we're going to provide
a little more insight than we normally
would especially like with heroes for
hire miss marvel
with miss marvel we're not necessarily
going to do a marvel explained in-depth
video the the section with miss marvel
will be about 9 or 10 minutes long so
you know we'll do a marvel explaining
video on her later
but we're really going to kind of
discuss her as a whole and we're really
going to kind of discuss the idea of how
not everyone who was against superhuman
registration
is openly acting the way that captain
america is that some people are trying
to circumvent registration
from within they're helping trying to
help people escape even though they're
pretending to be on the side of iron man
heroes for hire is going to provide some
pretty cool content you guys are going
to be able to see groups that you
wouldn't normally be able to see because
heroes for hire
is a very very small time group in
marvel comics they don't nearly have the
kind of prominence
or even the powers that we see in like
the avengers or
x-men or fantastic four or anything like
that and so heroes for hire will give
you guys a chance to see just how deep
this rift goes that um
that tony stark and then we're going to
really kind of uh i guess maybe get into
some unsavory things
in order to really kind of i guess even
more unsavory things to really kind of
try and capture
captain america so i'm hoping that these
videos are going to give you a more real
a well-rounded perspective of civil war
that is going to give you
like a more in-depth idea of the civil
war comics
but i'm i'm really hoping you guys are
enjoying the content so far you guys
really do
seem to be liking it again you know i'm
always open for criticism you know let
me know if there's something you guys
want to see change or something you guys
don't like too much
um i know that the the series might kind
of be wearing thin i know that it might
be to the point now where you guys are
like okay
i'm ready for civil war to wrap up you
know let's go ahead and move on to
something else
and i understand where you're coming
from you know but we have civil war
issue number five and then six and seven
and then we have the tie-ins and we're
done so hopefully within the next
you know a few weeks or so we can get
that series completely wrapped up
and we might even be able to do it
faster than that you know really just
kind of depends
you know having this 10 days off not
having to go to go back to work until
the 13th
really helps a lot because it means that
i can spend so much more time rather
than spending four hours a day
i can just sit here all day and just
crank and get videos done and get videos
uploaded for you guys
while still kind of maintaining the
content or still trying to maintain the
content of the
the standard that i've created for this
channel um but yeah i think you guys are
really going to enjoy the direction that
things are going and i think you guys
are really going to enjoy how we're
going to get into the civil war
and especially when we get towards the
end where we see the great big huge
event that's going on and and
you know again we're going to touch on
some stuff that we haven't really
touched on you know for example the
negative zone
we're going to talk about the negative
zone because that plays a huge role in
uh in the civil war event you know the
50-state initiative where they want to
have
a superhero team in every state that's
sanctioned by the government and
a portal to the negative zone in every
state that's going to be sanctioned by
the government so we're going to get
some really really cool stuff so i
really hope you guys are really enjoying
everything so far and and uh
and yeah so i hope you guys had a great
fourth of july weekend i know i did and
i had a great time
you know hanging out with my parents
with my dad and hanging out with my uh
my sister and hanging out with
some friends and whatnot it's it's been
a really good relaxing weekend this is
exactly what i needed
and uh and yeah so we're gonna be
cranking back to it this week we're
gonna be hammering out we're gonna be oh
just bam you know hammering right into
it and uh
and yeah so um with that being said i'm
gonna go and bring this video to an end
that's really all i wanted to say just
kind of check in with you guys and let
you guys know what's going on
and uh and yeah so uh i'll catch you
guys later
peace